is this on okay it's on
I meant that oh yeah you see the red
light okay I want to have one bit of
like real-deal honest emotion here okay
when I walked in here I walked out on
the stage and I kind of stopped for a
second and I was like you know you're on
the Oscar stage fella oh well you know
I'd like to think the Oscars have been
occupying our space for the Image Awards
for the last few years when I took over
hosting the show six years ago this was
always a mission of mine to bring it to
the Dolby not to discredit you know the
Pasadena Civic Auditorium or anything
like that but you know to have it in the
prestigious places this you know
especially what the Oscars being held
here every year so to walk out and to
see the theater the grandness of it it's
it's it's pretty amazing I can't think
of a better way to celebrate the 50th
anniversary of the n-double a-c-p Image
Awards then right here on this stage and
the Dolby theater and this is a
milestone moment for you and your career
as well just personally this is a
feather in my cap you know to host an
awards show as prestigious as the
n-double-a-cp Image Awards for for what
it means to us in our community and to
have it here in to be center stage and
celebrate the works that we've done
throughout this past year is truly a
blessing yeah I've been stocking your
Instagram and I've been seeing you on
playing the piano doing different
musical things have you been prepping
for your opening will you be on stage
with a piano you have a band can I play
the tambourine all I need is finger
snapping from you kind of like what
Johnny Gill did on that Janet Jackson
album you know many years ago when he
was credited for finger snaps I was like
really you get credits for finger
snapping on an album all right cool
that's that's all I need but don't be on
the 1 & 3 okay being don't be on the 1 &
2 okay something some of those of that
don't wanna give away what are you gonna
do you will be surprised you know our
opening acts have have been very fun for
the past five years with with with me
and and the crew here you know the image
Awards I don't know what we have in
store Anthony you're not telling the
truth you know exactly what you have in
store I will tell you this I am not
performed ma'am do not walk past here
there's an interview being conducted
[Laughter]
everyone gathered around here because
they're afraid of what you're gonna say
oh that's true okay seriously no
seriously 50th anniversary yeah give me
one support one thing that we can look
forward to that our viewers would be
like oh damn I got to know they're just
gonna have to tune in and see for
themselves
it's the Dolby Theatre meets in a state
hosting the 50th anniversary of the
n-double a-c-p Image Awards that's that
is what they should tune in for right
there I am hearing that everybody who's
anybody in Hollywood will be in this
building yes yes that's why we are in
this building and not at the community
Playhouse no I don't we don't have any
surprises as of yet I have yet to
rehearse anything for the show that's
Saturday and today is Wednesday oh I'm
gonna be surprised come Saturday night
as well okay yes did you party with the
Ross family last night
no I did not I guess my invitation was
lost in the mail Diana yeah I'm calling
you by your first name Diana what
happened to my invite I'm only your
daughter's fake husband on TV on the
most successful black sitcom in the
history of black sitcoms and I think I
started something the same I didn't get
an invite but you're invited to the
Image Awards cuz I'm a bigger person
okay and a serious question
Jesse Smollett was nominated for
Outstanding Supporting Actor mm-hmm do
you expect to see him
or Saturday night uh yeah I do I expect
everyone to be here in light of the
charges being dropped you know you're
not think I think that's a good thing
for him I think it's a good thing for
their show and and why not come out and
be celebrated with with his peers in his
community I wasn't there you know
so III reserve my my thoughts to myself
and into those that are intimate with me
but it they run the gamut you know it's
it's hard to see someone fabricating
something like that I mean but then if
you look at you know and listen to the
story you could understand why people
are trying to poke holes in it but I'm
happy the outcome is what it is
and I look forward to Jesse being here
and celebrating with everyone here and
being celebrated himself